Kanye West performed while dressed as a
giant bottle of Perrier water did yes
yeah such a weird costume okay and you
wonder like how about that yeah well
apparently they decided instead of like
let's get away from this they decided to
go towards it Wow
yes this is crazy but Perrier just
announced its going to be releasing a
limited edition bottle based on Kanye's
look yes isn't that crazy and they asked
me to debut it for the first time ever
live on our show this is not here it is
it's Perrier 'he's new Kanye West's very
easy bottle these are available forever
Perrier assault yeah this is crazy it
sells for just a little more than a
regular bottle of Perrier oh yeah a
couple hundred bucks extra and not only
does it look like Kanye but when you
open it you'll hear an exclusive Kanye
isn't this is the craziest thing check
it out look look
imma let you finish but first let's
praise our glorious leader president
true it's just a nod I don't know if
that's the kind of thing that people are
gonna let's see if their San Pellegrino
doesn't care about black people wait a
minute that's a terrible thing to say
about San Pellegrino what's going on you
want some real refreshment a bottle is
213th them you know hey how would you
explain that to your children oh yeah I
wouldn't know how to explain it to
anyone yeah it's very strange but
apparently these are available and
they're gonna just go like hotcakes
all right I'm certain of it and what a
pleasant way to enjoy a refreshing
why that delayed applause I don't know
did someone hit an applause but no no it
was a collective urge it just felt like
it came out of nowhere it was like the
bit was over and people are like all
right
you could feel people go all right shows
free whatever there's some noise of
transition yeah whatever you know it was
starting to rain we came inside it's
fine and then yeah it felt ill time to
me that's why
you